How do you create relationships online when you're just starting to court each other?
So, let me think about the ways that I would maybe connect with someone that I didn't know already.
First of all, absolutely critical that you read their profile...
...because you have to make sure when you send a message that it's personal.
Nobody wants to see a message that looks like it's been cut and pasted in...
...so I would look at someone's profile.
Every profile has something interesting to say...
...and I would say something like,...
"I really enjoyed the blog you wrote on the 24th of March about such and such a subject."
"I'd be interested to hear what happened to you after that blog went out."...
...or "I see you've got a network of 40 people, but you've managed to achieve 12 testimonials."...
..."I'd love to learn from you because that's a fantastic achievement."...
...or "I've just seen a photograph on your profile of a place you went on holiday."
"Did you have a great time?"
"What kind of sort of holiday do you plan to take next year?"
Something sort of showing an interest in their profile.
Pick out things that they do in their business that undoubtedly would be of interest to you.
I mean, most people are in business all doing similar sorts of things,...
...you know, even if you're a graphic designer, accountancy is gonna be important to you;...
...property development is going to be important to you.
Pick out something in their profile that's of interest to you as well...
...and so make sure that you at all times personalize the way that you talk to someone...
...and 100% if you show an interest in somebody, they will show an interest back in you.